the problem for Holiday Travelers last
week of course was getting to their
Christmas destination now it's getting
back home in the midst of a once in a
generation storm and not just those in
the storm's path but all across the
nation including right here where it's
been sunny all day Ryan Matthew joining
us live from the airport with today's
travel troubles Ryan
yeah David Denise just by noon today 300
flights here at Harry Reid were canceled
it's now climbing a bit close to that
350 Mark and that's hundreds more
flights canceled than this time last
week or even later last week when the
storm was first starting now Travelers
here they say they're not surprised to
see all of this extra activity in action
here but how the flights and the
airlines rather are responding to all
this change is what's taking them back
holiday headaches and thousands of
tiring Travelers it's like they only
hire idiots ahead of another upcoming
holiday weekend this winter storm
continues to blow through people's plans
my wife's mom will be very upset
but it is what it is families like the
luells spent the Christmas holiday
locally but delay after delay leaves
uncertainty of making it to Tennessee
for a decades-long New Year's tradition
with families I feel mad because I lost
money but the increasing rebookings from
days prior are putting strain on crowd
size Travelers report waiting in
check-in lines hours long by the time
Francisco teroso got to the front his
flight to Texas was taking off then
forced to choose between waiting three
days for a rebooked flight or shelling
out thousands for new tickets 13 hours
later they don't give me like an excuse
they just like say that I was late but I
was like two hours before my flight so I
don't know what they say that they said
last night I probably didn't show up
please go home cancellations and delays
leaving some people stranded this couple
vacationing in Florida had a two-hour
layover in Las Vegas that climbed to 21
hours before being canceled they were
told bags were in route to Oregon only
to find them still at the airport
they're now forced to fly nearly to
Canada to get a car rental to drive
another four and a half hours home this
discount airlines are really showing
their value with their behavior in the
way that they're treating their
customers
now some major airlines are offering to
waive change fees and fair differences
and in some certain scenarios even
booking them a hotel room for the night
but most of the Travelers we spoke to
today said that even though they were
told they would receive some of those
benefits they haven't seen them so far
reporting live from Harry Reid
International Ryan Matthey 8 news now a
lot of headache and frustration Ryan
thank you so here's a look at those
cancellations and delays so far today
over my shoulder 332 canceled
229 delayed the storm expected to
persist now for even more days along
with these traveling headaches David